in december billionaires elon musk and
larry ellison announced separately that
they were leaving california
but the golden state is still a
billionaire mecca california added 24
new billionaires over the past year
securing its reign as the state with the
most billionaires at 189
altogether 732 of the 2755 members of
the 2021 forbes billionaire list
live in the us including non-us citizens
like ireland's john and patrick collison
the brothers who founded san
francisco-based payment firm stripe
large states dominate the top 10 states
for these tycoons
7 out of the 10 most populous u.s states
are also home to the most
billionaires new york florida and texas
take the second third and fourth spots
on our list
massachusetts a tech hub that rounds out
the top
five has seven more billionaires than a
year ago
the vaccine effort spurred by the covet
19 pandemic
minted several new biotech billionaires
who live in the state
this includes stefan bonsell the ceo of
cambridge massachusetts-based vaccine
maker moderna
seven states don't have any billionaire
residents that forbes could find
that's alabama alaska delaware new
hampshire
north dakota vermont and west virginia
jim justice the governor of west
virginia
used to be a billionaire but earlier
this year was revealed to have borrowed
850 million dollars from green cell
capital
a uk-based lender that has filed for
insolvency
california doesn't just have the highest
number of billionaire residents
it also has the highest combined
billionaire net worth
the state's 189 billionaires are worth a
combined 1.04
trillion dollars at number two new
york's billionaire residence combined
net worth is 672.7 billion dollars
florida's combined net worth is 245.1
billion dollars
texas billionaires have a combined net
worth of 460.1 billion dollars
and massachusetts combined net worth is
102 billion dollars
[Music]